judge mershon set the next court date as
December 4th so already there will be
eight months until the next court date
Trump's lawyers are asking for more time
which could already push this into
January or even spring of 2024. now
there's two sides to the delay tactic on
the one hand most many all attorneys in
criminal circumstances will often say
you want to delay as much as you can the
more you delay
the more you are potentially benefiting
yourself as the defendant for a number
of different reasons Witnesses could
forget
or they could die or they could refuse
to be involved or whatever the longer
you wait the weaker the case might
become for the prosecution due to things
that happen with Witnesses evidence
evidence could be lost misplaced tainted
whatever the case may be